depending on where you live you see
coyotes in your neighborhood but a
warning this afternoon there's been an
increase in sightings yeah you got to be
careful sally jeremiah says if you have
pets be especially careful between dusk
and dawn
chase is only three months
so we are really nervous as we hear more
and more coyotes being around
especially as the season is changing
concern on the rise for pet owners as
their furry friends could go missing you
know as as las vegas or any major
metropolitan area
grows we have increased interactions
along that
what we call wildland urban interface
doug nielsen conservation education
supervisor for the nevada department of
wildlife says southern nevada is no
stranger to creatures like mice
squirrels rabbits coyotes and even
mountain lions without the moisture that
we get from especially the summer
monsoons but also those winter rains
we don't have the groceries out on the
desert floor and now even letting your
pet out in your own backyard unattended
is risky michael canir chief medical
officer at sun city animal hospital says
they've had many animals come to the
hospital because of the severity of some
attacks in the past uh 14 days we've had
five uh come in and so that is a little
bit above the norm unfortunately
they're they're predatory animals so
they're gonna go ahead and you know look
at your pet not as a play mate but as a
food source and kaneer doesn't want you
to be fearful but instead extra cautious
before chase i did have a kitten the cat
fighting the coyote and they were able
to separate them so they thought of that
happening to chase drives me crazy sally
kanamiyo live local now